so protests have erupted across Pakistan
after the rest of former prime minister
Imran Khan Khan was arrested by Security
Forces at the high court in the capital
Islamabad he was there to face
corruption charges which he says are
politically motivated mobile internet
was suspended on government orders as
the protests grew government officers
and schools would be closed Nationwide
on Wednesday
the Army headquarters in raupindi was
one of several sensitive sites targeted
in Lahore demonstrators torched and
vandalized the residents of the corps
Commander
was targeted that's the headquarters of
Pakistan's paramilitary Frontier Force
protesters also entered the Hamza Camp
of Pakistan's spy agency the
inter-services intelligence or isi
Andrew van Vick as this report
sticks stones and Flames
pouring of anger across Pakistan
it's not the government that's the prime
target of this Theory but the military
in unprecedented scenes supporters are
former prime minister Imran Khan stormed
the Army headquarters in Rawalpindi as
well as the paramilitary Francia Force
Headquarters
people are blaming the military for
Khan's erased at a court in Islamabad
what they have done is this not
hooliganism is this not terrorism
this is the Lahore residence of the top
Army commander in Punjab
protesters stormed it and set parts of
light taking out their frustrations on
his belongings
Khan had predicted his arrest just
before his court appearance the Ubi
together
let me make it clear as I'm leaving for
Islamabad they don't need to bring
police Rangers frantic or an Army in
great numbers as it would cost the
national treasury a lot if someone has
warrants to arrest me then come to me
with warrants my lawyers will be there
I'm ready to go to jail
[Music]
shortly after arriving at the court Khan
was dragged out of his car shoved into
another vehicle and driven away his
supporters are calling it an abduction
it was illegal and it denotes very
clearly that there is no writ of law
that there is no writ of the civilian
government and clearly things are being
run in the country on a might as right
and the control is not in the hands of
any civilian government at all and many
have called for Nationwide protests
we are not scared of anyone we are not
afraid of death we are here and we will
be here until the free Imran Khan we
will block the whole of Pakistan
you can see the fires here this is a
battle for real Freedom which will
continue till Imran Khan is freed no
matter how long it takes days months or
years we will be standing here to the
freedom of Imran Khan
the government has suspended mobile and
broadband internet services as the
violence spread across multiple cities
police have used tear gas and water
cannon on crowds of people who are
calling Tuesday's events a grave
Injustice
Andrea van wyk Al Jazeera
Osama bin Javed has more now from
Islamabad
just hours after the arrest of Imran
Khan the high court in Islamabad has
deemed the arrest illegal proceeding as
the Pakistan had been alleging that
Imran Khan was abducted from the
judicial complex by the national
accountability Bureau and the
paramilitary ranges it is worth noting
that Imran Khan is going to be presented
at the national accountability Bureau at
8 00 a.m in the morning in Pakistan
which is going to be 0-300 GMT that's
when Pakistan has asked all its workers
to gather at the judicial complex to
protest against the arrest of Imran Khan
who have been protesting across the
country in their hundreds public
property has been damaged and scenes
that we have not seen for years in
Pakistan is the military establishment
has been challenged by protesters
belonging to the Pakistan they've
entered the residences of core
commanders the military General
headquarter and other military
residences and building on its path the
government says that every when who is
going to be found to be ransacking
places accused of vandalism is going to
be dealt with according to the interior
minister with an iron hand so Pakistan
plunges deeper into this period of
uncertainty as Imran Khan has been
arrested he is are going to be taken
into remand according to the National
accountability Bureau as the proceedings
continue and his party continues to call
this a politically motivated Saga
against a popular leader of Pakistan